I was gonna say that was strange why we
do you mean acid never this was pure
weed that's a day did you do it when you
were on sand that live like gonna come
up in comedy all those years uh yeah
yeah I've been affected it was um it's
not a blow involved there's no blow in
our cast no it was all weed
oh maybe boozing weed and booze goes
along with the creativity right I mean
weed a lot of people do it like well I
started or there's weed all I start
doing numb myself because why you
weren't happy
oh it's frustrating so first it's a
tough frustrating invite it was inside
life
the environment is really it's a
pressure cooker right like some people
love it and some people hate it I loved
it it's just it's not the easiest for
comedian cuz you're up you're up working
on weather monkey or [ __ ] is a funnier
word you're carving out every sketch
right you're fighting for your
characters
you're fighting free characters you're
you're working on things on stage you
know it works on stage yeah and then you
come back and you got 40 Pinot
you're competing with 14 people trying
to write to get their thing on up with
10 15 cast members trying to get their
thing on go to his cast Jen I'm sorry
life but it was one of the greatest
times ever at my whole life and then
when when something like goat boy goes
freaking I mean just not the biggest
thing ever
where were you a little like because
they were using a lot more we kinda like
come on let's do something else or did
you love it
no to be honest with you I hate
repetition that's right absolutely yeah
not so but when once in a while Lorne
would go Jim we could really use the
goat this week but dude can I be honest
with you so that was my second year of
MADtv we come back we were like we're
gonna beat SNL right right and it was
that one foot it was so so you guys
opened it was the first time you ever
did go poi and it was when Tom Hanks Tom
Hanks bro that was the first and I say
as somebody we were all set around the
cast to watch you guys and when he
marries Shearer Brailler day I'm working
with Tim Meadows right now by the way I
love him
doing school with him that's one way he
might go Blair no I'm sure yeah I'm so
so so dude I'm telling you right now Jim
we were all sing around here we were
ready for the next season and you guys
got on it was one of the greatest
episodes that episode that over the way
you open is run the greatest episodes
ever and all of us kind of hung our
heads when I saw Gopal what meri share
the great Mary sheer of growling started
laughing so hard we were laughing so
[ __ ] are so outrageous mad and you're
drinking from the oh my god and we were
like what we're done we're [ __ ]
we're never gonna compete with these
guys they're just too good well two
things one is you're not gonna find a
goalie sketch mmm what Tom Hanks no no
I'm good at all the go boys are missing
why I have no clue the actual sketches
of goat boy with the Tom Hanks and the
Pamela Anderson and all that I don't
know why the time was incredible every
single one of them is just missing
they're gone well you can't go on SNL
site you can't go on NBC site why is
that I live release them I have them
zero clue I think it's the only
character that's terrible where it's
nowhere such up so cuz my kids were
trying to look for this they haven't
seen it and they were like you were to
Tom Hanks so I asked oh thing like what
you it was such an imam Hanks left so he
Joey he was laughing he laughed so hard
but it wasn't supposed to be that by the
way I was totally aggravated with the
sketch turned into you know here's I
pitched it as a guy with Tourette's
that's like a [ __ ] did I when I want to
do a guy Tourette's but its Tourette's
is a goat noise and
originally this is true originally I'm
from Tourette's to goat boy right so
check this out so I said he when he's
nervous around women and when he sings
it comes out so if he likes to check you
I came and I think you beautiful and so
there's no rhyme or reason why he had
this and that led to I'm singing I and
the first so start spread in the and
then it didn't everyone looked at me I
go nuts really in the room that hit love
it they thought I was psyched about a
year later they tried it as go boy sings
80 songs and it was only a two minute
thing so just me going you can dance and
you want to your friends behind and
shout shout let it all so ended the
first season was on second season Tom
Hanks is on and the guy that did it with
me goes I swear to god he goes goes all
right you know the go thing all right
what if the government had a secret
weapon but it but it failed so now
they're stuck with this poor half-goat
thing and so but he loves singing songs
so he only sings 80 songs cuz that's his
program do and then II and then vh1
gives him a show it's called go boy hey
remember the 80s but hosted by go boys
and like well I poet white I'm all over
it I said no like yeah we're gonna put
you in a hole and little did we know to
this twenty years later we're laughing
ball any five stupid
and when you're drinking from the what
would they cut away at Thomas we all
lost again one way to cut away Tom Hanks
and you're like drinking oh I think from
an otter or something I call Hanks one
did Tom Hanks go boy
I saw something you can figure out the
conspiracy why all the goat boys are
missing
honestly explained your cast was amazing
Jim yeah I mean yet one of the molly was
a powerhouse Cheri Oteri as a powerhouse
Will Ferrell's beyond superstar yeah
Tracy Morgan belly laugh and funny
Cheryl ham and oh my god III saw Darrell
the other night at the comic store oh
good for ya good I miss him
yeah do you stay connected with everyone
or not really not really
you know who dies though you like you
everyone's so busy that you don't like
them but it's like when you're not in
the same Lane
like when you're not striving for the
same girl and work like yet family thing
when I call him and I left the world
after this what do you mean I was done I
was done with Hollywood done with the
rats I just was done why I was exhausted
why we end up
it was Lena Jim the show that the
lead-up to Senate Live was so exhausting
just mentally I already had it I just I
had and it takes the fun I had it took
the lot of fun it took the event I had
vengeance towards you know triple
Hollywood and I had a major triple I was
older and I'm not chip on my shoulder on
sorry I live for how long three years
and then you get done white why do you
have a chip on your shoulder with the
chip so it was delete this is the long
lead up so when I first when I started
doing stand-up was in high school but
then when I got serious was 1989
it was on and off and in 1989 I went
this is what I'm doing and how old were
you 18 I won 18 no 89 85 so like 21 21
years old I go this is what I'm doing
forever okay and I started and I was
living in Florida so I'm touring rounds
comedian and then worked my way to a
middle act 30 minutes and then and then
I knew it was time doing a road and then
then it was time to go to New York LA
back to New York where I'm from and I
got in TV pretty quick I got a
I was on a show called the Uptown comedy
club which was filmed in Harlem which is
where me and Tracy Morgan first oh wow
Tracy Morgan when I met him on the
Uptown comedy club he would always show
up with those hats almost like the way
Spanky wore and Lou Rascals yeah but it
had a little propeller on top and he
would come in for hours we'd get nothing
done cuz he would just come in and rant
for an hour I was on the subway nod my
man choo-choos rogue mama mama had his
bottlenecks huh and she was she was
raging
she waited because of children did my
auntie would cause he's watch him he was
so wonderfully odd and he would and he
would put in these crazy details that
was they would paint the pitch and he
was so funny so after that show then me
and Chappelle were up for uh baked knows
before a half-baked mean him I had a
huge development deal with NBC he had a
huge deal with HBO Dave and at the last
second we got pulled from our deals so
we can together beyond this Disney show
called buddies interesting and we were
on the cover of TV Guide the commercials
on it was a spinoff of home improvement
so we went on a home improvement and
then the second episode while my
commercials that flew my best friend's
out for the premiere and I got fired
that's how it works I'm ill the second
episode because however no business
never the most frustrating thing was and
never they don't tell you yeah like did
I suck did I know I did whatever the
reason was yeah
so it's gladder e-tickets taken away so
from there that makes you upset oh no no
no so from there I mean it's devastating
for sure business though and its
business and then you're frustrated
because before that I was with the with
um I wanna say his name was Pollak he he
was Will Smith's producer for that
show Fresh Prince of bel-air and sign
this deal with NBC's so they can develop
heat they met Will Smith and like this
is gonna be great so to get pulled from
that to break that contract so we can
guarantee go on the air with Dave
Chappelle Chappelle was pulled from HBO
he was banned from HBO Jesus there was a
big lawsuit yeah why he banned I can't
remember because he because they deal he
had the original Chris Rock deal which
was two one-hour specials in his own
talk show and he was only 20 21 so then
that and I get fired from that for what
whatever mmm
whatever the reason okay two days later
Fox says are upset that you've got can
you audition for us today and I
auditioned it was Herman's head or
something whatever shows that she and I
got it I liked that and I got it
yeah I got the show and Disney at the
times did you not allowed to do it
because we don't have a contract with
Fox and you're still with us Jesus so
here now I'm trapped so I get fired and
now I can't even not getting even get
work some rage against machine and then
that goes and then they say it's gonna
be a pickup and then it doesn't get
picked up and then then I got clerks and
then from clerks they fired Chris
Schmitt they couldn't be part of the
project and then the we picked it up and
then they didn't pick it up and they
fire the the star and it was just a big
it was nuts and then Senate life came we
how many did you audition just once or
did you don't know I was the last guy's
as the last guy hired so I time so you
go through six previously right then you
you test you go in you come back you do
it for producers you [ __ ] how made
you do just now here's what I did I
auditioned and I didn't want to audition
I said oh no no I I know Jay I know some
people that are on there and they are it
made them ugly well you like change
their made them ugly people like being
president yeah and so uh and so with
that I auditioned and the next day in
the new
paper it said sanity lives searching for
our all-new cast nation one of those
already written off comedian Jim Breuer
who had two sitcoms go bust on him and a
man I want know knows who I was you mm
why would you like that a newspaper what
what well it was a my hate everyone's
like man I can't believe they wrote that
and watered it and then they asked me to
go back like why am I gonna go back they
clearly you wrote in the paper yeah and
then I went back and then they met with
me and then that was awkward and then
what did you do in your audition did you
do remember I am some people do like
multiple characters and sometimes do one
yeah usually I don't even if five
characters I know what MADtv was like
five care I wasn't good at the
characters I really wasn't
I'm not for the audition oh that was so
eventually I was the last guy hired and
when you stoked when you got found out
the news no I was exhausted I was
completely exhausted
really yeah I'd even know if I really
had here's the whole process you were
exhausted yeah and then right before I
got it there was uh I remember meeting
and I was told you knows a lot of people
here that are not fans you being on the
show and there's a lot pulling for you
so thank you guys thank oh that's true
no and that's now correct me if I'm
wrong you can be fired any minute yeah
rightly so do you never have job
security you're never that few don't
start doing more characters but that's
why they put out monsters well yeah that
the pressure like same with today it's
saying with sports yeah right score zero
point hunter person's fights you don't
have a job percent right so so it just
creates a it creates a tempo in your own
in your body and your mind though even
when you get the job you're never
relaxed you never relaxed and then so
once I got it though I loved the
environment it was frustrating but so
worth it when you hit that home run
yeah and then in houses you know it's
frustrating you this writer
paying your ass and this guy doesn't
like you it's just and then how did you
know it was time to leave
when you left there you had a big chip
initial just because then I was
exhausted there was the guys that pushed
me to be on left the leather towards the
end of the second season I was on and my
hand of God their words to me or like
Jim your we quit this guy Fred wolf and
Steve corn they quit and they said uh
good luck man because they're coming at
you I well who's coming at me don't get
it he's coming at you I won't say who
but um and then I realized that last
year like oh my god people are oh my god
somebody like Machiavellian right and
you never expected you're like what and
then then it's so that battle and the
the stories go on and on and I'm so I'm
past them a halt and healed from it all
but Abed but I've had friends you've
gotten fired from that show yeah and
after five six years and that good six
years right and there's nobody tells you
you just hear from your agent that
you're you're thrown the press well I
actually got to talk to Lauren oh you
did which is incredible did they let you
go or you decided to leave here's
exactly how it went down
this is with Lauren the whole thing yes
at the end of the third season they I
got a call from an NBC executive and he
said Jim what happened this year what
are you talking about he said so-and-so
and so-and-so are doing everything they
can to get you fired what not I knew
exactly he was talking to I went I can't
is it cast members or writers writers
kind that's terrible and so I went whoa
what and so I got a nice like man I'm
just telling you this is what so I
called each one mm-hmm one game one
wouldn't take my call one did and he
told he was like oh no
boo-boo the Hollywood talk a playpal
you're my you're my guy actually we're
trying to get someone else fired it goes
no not you I don't know
I had an an NBC executive said I can get
fired for telling you this yeah but this
is I mean this is my kids lives it's a
true story
so I knew this other guy was a problem
so I I told I went to my refs and what I
don't want to be on that show anymore if
he's the main person it's not where it's
not worth my health amount it's just not
worth it
am I gonna lose out on a great show and
all that no work environment is worth
that in my in my in my mind and so Lorne
talked to me and he said Loren he said
Jim why don't you once you once you have
dinner with the guy I said I'll try and
that's right and it wasn't working out
and then and then Laura and I asked to
be released and Lauren said Jim if you
ever need anything call me I'm your guy
and you're too nice for this business
you're just too nice for this but Jesus
and that's it that's what the great
Lorne Michaels said to me and I've
always said he's always had the highest
respect for him yeah yeah yeah you know
some people whatever he does he does I
mean well you can say whatever you want
that guy is a genius jeez and he's if I
he's really great comedic figures of the
20th century and still greatest in some
ways as far as a facilitator producer
understanding what works how to make
great people he takes he could creates
greatness a tepee he also creates that
environment where you either sinkers
well well that daddy I don't know if you
had the audition of the audition that
the audition process I've heard from
people like Amy Poehler and Taran Killam
and I mean it's the audition process is
like America's great like the Navy SEAL
I had a part of Mac more and I told him
because I had the key tomorrow when I
win a March show Lauren asked me he
pulled me in the room you know I said
Lauren wants to talk to you
okay and I sat down and Lauren asked me
about two different people that he
wanted to hire one was Marc Maron and he
said Jim what do you think of Marc Maron
and my exact words were now this was
then I said well a lot of people don't
like him and I said I'm I don't like him
either
however if you're talking about hiring
him for the Update desk
I think he'd be he'd be one of the best
I go but as a person I can't stand him
he's just difficult back then right he's
a dick yeah that's what everybody was
blog thing about it being yeah he was
the big is he admits it though and
that's the he minute when I shown we
talked about it yeah I thought he was
very insecure back then like that's what
I always got yeah yeah and and why that
would drive people like me nuts cuz I'm
always a you're an open book I'm all
been bugging them all for one one for
all
I mean me too you beat me out you beat
me out right now
yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your tongue oh
good what's gonna happen what are you
gonna do use some of that boxing you've
been doing
[Laughter]